PROFESSOR: Today,
we're going to continue
with the adiabatic subject.
And our main topic is
going to be Berry's Phase.
It's interesting
part of the phase
that goes in adiabatic process.
And we want to
understand what it is
and why people care about it.
And then, we'll turn
to another subject
in which the adiabatic
approximation is of interest.
And it's a subject of molecules.
So I don't think I'll manage to
get through all of that today,
but will we'll make an effort.
So let me remind you
of what we had so far.
So we imagine we have
a Hamiltonian that
depends on time and
maybe had no dependents
before time equals 0 turns on.
And it has no further
variation after some time t.
So the Hamiltonian
changes like that.
And the adiabatic theorem
states that if you
have a state at
time equals 0, which
is a particular instantaneous
eigenstate, that
is the instantaneous
eigenstate, then
that's the full wave function at
time equals 0 and it coincides.
Then, at time at any time in
this process, if it's slow,
the process, the
state of the system,
the full wave
function, psi of t,
will tend to remain in that
instantaneous eigenstate.
And the way it's
stated precisely
is that psi of t minus--
I'll write it like this--
psi prime n of t, the
norm of this state
is of order 1/T for any
t in between 0 and T.
So I'm trying to state the
adiabatic theorem in a way that
is mathematically precise.
And let me remind you the
norm of a wave function
is you integrate the
wave function square
and take the square root.
It's sort of the
usual definition
of the norm of a vector is the
inner product of the vector
with itself square root.
So that's the norm
for wave function.
And here, what this means is
that with some suitable choice
of phase, the
instantaneous eigenstate
is very close to the true state.
And the error is a Fourier
1/T. So if the process is slow,
it means that the change
occurs over long t,
this is a small number.
And there is some
instantaneous eigenstate
with some peculiar phase--
that's why I put the prime--
for which this
difference is very small.
And we calculated
this phase, and we
found the state, psi
of t is roughly equal
to e to theta n of t, e to the
I gamma n of t, psi n of t.
And in this statement,
this is what I would
call the psi n prime of t.
And that's why the real
state is just approximately
equal to that one.
And we have these phases in
which theta of t is minus 1
over h bar integral from 0
to t E n of t prime dt prime.
That is kind of
a familiar phase.
If you had a normal energy
eigenstate, time independent 1,
this would be 1 to the--
well, would be minus e
times t over h bar with an I
would be the familiar
phase that you
put to an energy eigenstate.
Then it comes the
gamma n of t, which
is an integral from 0 to t of
some new n of t prime dt prime.
And this new n of t is I
psi n of t psi n dot of t.
I think I have it right.
So the second part of
the phase is the integral
of this new function.
And this new function is
real, because this part
we showed before is imaginary,
where with an I, this is real.
And this second
part, this gamma n,
is called the geometric phase.
This is the phase that has
to do with Berry's phase.
And it's a phase that
we want to understand.
And it's geometrical
because of one reason
that we're going
to show that makes
it quite surprising and quite
different from the phase theta.
The phase theta is a
little like a clock,
because it runs with time.
The more time you
wait on an energy
eigenstate, the more
this phase changes.
What will happen with
this geometric phase
is that somehow
properly viewed is
independent of the time it takes
the adiabatic process to occur.
So whether it takes us
small time or a long time
to produce this
change of the system,
the geometric phase will
be essentially the same.
That's very, very unusual.
So that's the main thing
we want to understand
about this geometric
phase, that it depends only
on the evolution of the state
in that configuration space--
we'll make that
clear, what it means--
and not the time it takes
this evolution to occur.
It's a little more subtle, this
phase, than the other phase.
So I want to introduce this
idea of a configuration space.
So basically, we have that--
let me forget about time
dependence for one second
and think of the
Hamiltonian as a function
of a set of coordinates,
or parameters.
So the Rs are some coordinates.
R1, R2, maybe up to R capital
N are some coordinates
inside some vector space RN.
So its N components.
And what does that mean?
It means maybe that
your Hamiltonian
has capital N parameters.
And those are these things.
So you buy this Hamiltonian.
It comes with some parameters.
You buy another one.
It comes with another
set of parameters.
Those parameters can be changed.
Or you construct them in
the lab, your Hamiltonians
with different parameters.
Those are the parameters
of the Hamiltonian.
And suppose you have
learned to solve
this Hamiltonian for all
values of the parameters.
That is whatever the
Rs are you know how
to find the energy eigenstates.
So H of R times--
there are some eigenstates, psi
n of R with energies En of R,
psi n of R. And n
maybe is 1, 2, 3.
And these are
orthonormal states,
those energy eigenstates.
So this equation
says that you have
been able to solve this
Hamiltonian whatever
the values of the
parameters are.
And you have found all
the states of the system,
n equal 1, 2 3, 4, 5, 6.
All of them are in now.
So this is a general situation.
And now, we imagine
that for some reason,
these parameters start to
begin to depend on time.
So they become time
dependent parameters--
can become time dependent.
So that you now
have R of t vector.
These are 1 of t
up to our Rn of t.
So how do we represent this?
Well, this is a Cartesian
space of parameters.
This is not our normal space.
This is a space where one axis
could be the magnetic field.
Another axis could be
the electric field.
the spring constant.
Those are abstract axis
of configuration space.
Or this could be R1,
R2, the axis, R3.
And those are your axes.
And now, how do you represent
in this configuration space
the evolution of the system?
What is the evolution of the
system in this configuration
space?
How does it look?
Is it a point?
A line?
A surface?
What is it?
Sorry?
STUDENT: A path.
PROFESSOR: It's a path.
It's a line.
Indeed, you look at your clock.
And at time equals 0,
well, it takes some values.
And you're fine, OK,
here it at time equals 0.
At time equal 1,
the values change.
There's one parameter,
which is time.
So this traces a path.
As time goes by, the core in
this changing in time and this
is a line
parameterized by time--
so a path gamma
parameterized by time.
And that represents the
evolution of your system.
At time equals 0, this point
could be R at t equals 0.
And maybe this point
is R a t equal T final.
And this system is
going like that.
You should imagine the system as
traveling in that configuration
space.
That's what it does.
That's why we put the
configuration space.
And we now have a set--
not the set-- a time
dependent Hamiltonian,
because while H was a function
of R from the beginning, now
R is a function of time.
So this is your new Hamiltonian.
And this is time dependent--
dependent Hamiltonian.
But now, the
interesting thing is
that the work you did
before in finding the energy
eigenstates for any position
in this configuration space
is giving you the instantaneous
energy eigenstates,
because if this equation here
holds for any value of R,
it certainly holds for the
values of R corresponding
to some particular time.
So psi n of R of t is equal to
En of R of t psi n of R of t.
So it's an interesting
interplay in which
the act that you know your
energy eigenstates everywhere
in your configuration
space allows
you to find the
time evolved states,
the time dependent energy
eigenstates, the instantaneous
energy eigenstates
are found here.
So what we want to do now
is evaluate in this language
the geometric phase, this phase.
I want to understand
what this phase is
in this geometric language.